this is a production of cornell
university
so thanks very much i appreciate the
opportunity to um speak to the
horticulture today
about this really uh bizarre event and i
think so how many of you grow tomatoes
and yeah and how many of you had
problems in 2009
yeah
so it was absolutely bizarre and i
thought i'd just like to explain a
little bit about that
some of the
it was uh it was a pandemic it made
the national and international news
here's
a quote from the new york times on the
17th of july 2009
says a highly contagious fungus that
destroys tomato plants has quickly
spread to nearly every state in the
northeast and the mid-atlantic and the
weather over the next week may determine
whether the outbreak a base of whether
tomato crops are ruined
and then in august
there was this headline that appeared in
the new york times and according to this
guy he says you say tomato i say
agricultural disaster
and that was um from an organic tomato
grower who ships directly to high-end
markets in new york city
and he lost a lot of his tomatoes that
year and i think many people had the
same experience throughout the northeast
actually my tomatoes weren't too bad
um
in 2009
i went to um empire farm days on uh in
august
and i was talking with some people and
the guy who lived not too far from me a
couple miles away and i lived in the
town of anfield he said i lost all my
tomatoes i thought whoa i'm going to
start spraying my my tomatoes so i did
and um i actually did okay in 2009.
uh what i want to do is to give you some
very introductory comments there may be
a few of you who
don't know that much about late blight
uh if you have questions about late
blight i'm going to pass them to brian
because i talk a lot about late blight
in my class
and
i'm going to talk first of all about
migrations of the pathogen phytophthora
infestant worldwide migrations but also
migrations that have happened within the
united states
a focus specifically on what happened in
2009 and then what's happened subsequent
to 2009 and i'll finish by giving some
predictions
about management of this particular
disease
i want to uh describe to you um
actually what i should do is ask brian
to describe this
this is the
um
asexual cycle of phytophthora infestance
but i just wanted to illustrate it to
you
this organism reproduces by producing
sporangia
and this is a micrograph of a sporangium
here it's giving birth to a zoaspore
these zoa spores are about 10
micrometers in diameter
and they're interesting because they
have two flagella here's a schematic
drawing of them a forward directed
tensile type flagellum and a posterior
directed
whiplash flagellum and they they are
immortal for
minutes to up to an hour
if
this
zoa spore lands on a leaf and causes
penetrates the leaf it can produce a
very small lesion that looks like this
in about three or possibly four days
it's um takes at least two two and a
half to three days before you see any
symptom at all and this is probably
three to four days old
within a couple days that lesion can
expand and the pathogen has grown
throughout this tissue
and if that lesion is subjected to very
moist weather leap wetness for 10 11 or
12 hours
it can sporulate brian how am i doing
pretty good so far okay thanks
all right
so
so this is a lot this is the pathogen
sporulating on leaf now brian how many
sporangia are on that lease
he wants to hear your question
no it's brian he doesn't deserve it all
right
that goes with the name
um
so this is a
potato leaflet this passage goes to both
tomatoes and potatoes it's actually more
famous as i'll say in just a minute as a
potato pathogen than as a tomato
pathogen that is two people have worked
with it for a long time people who grow
tomatoes don't know that
necessarily but but it is anyway um
there are probably more than a million
sporangia on that uh leaflet
um
and if you were to look at this with a
dissection scope or a hand lens you'd
see the sporangia among the trichomes on
this potato leaf if you look at it
through a compound microscope you'd see
the
sporangiophores and here's the
sporangium
when the weather changes in the morning
particularly and the dew dries off of
the leaf
these sporangia
are actually
discharged
and
here's one that has
been discharged and these can be
aerially dispersed
if they land on a surface that has free
moisture they can germinate
so this is the asexual cycle
it's really dramatically important it
can
happen in between four and a half to
five days depending on whether depending
upon how susceptible the
the um
the host crop is
and it's um it's really quite dramatic
and it's so dramatic that it can turn a
field of potatoes that looks something
like this within
eight or nine or ten days to a field of
potatoes that looks something like that
and in other another eight or nine days
it can look something like this so i can
tell you that every last bit of potato
full and this is a potato field thank
you brian
every last bit of tomat potato foliage
has been destroyed now you'll see some
green here and here that's pigweed
and this is
a grass of some sort
but all of the potato foliage
was dead i took this picture in august
of 1994. this is a late season cultivar
it should have been green until
mid-october mid-september excuse me so
it was totally dead
um well over a month before it should
have been and that was caused by late
blight caused by phytophthora infestands
so in addition destroying destroying
foliage
this pathogen also infects tubers
and this is a really important fact is
that the pathogen can overwinter in
infected tubers in a potato storage
or if there are tubers left in the soil
and and the tubers don't freeze
then can survive in volunteers the next
year or it can survive in great big
piles of cold potatoes
one of which is pictured here
and
this is i took this picture in i think
1994 also
and
actually don halseth is pictured in this
um this image john do you know where you
are
you were in steven county yeah but i
mean right here
it's really good you know where you are
um
so that this uh this is a
tons and tons of
tubers that were dumped because this the
grower had harvested the tubers
about a week previously he'd had late
blight in the field it was really warm
and wet that harvest season those
conditions are just perfect for
infection by with phytophthora
infestands
so the potatoes were put into storage
they were warm they were wet
and in
late blight lesions on a tuber are
spectacular places for erwinia karatavra
or pectobacterium
sorry brain pectobacterium keratovrum
can infect and cause soft rot and so
these potatoes were just melting in
storage it was just just going down and
it was it was a huge storage john do you
remember how large
that was it was
about okay about ten thousand hundred
weight
so the uh can you imagine the these
potatoes were about four or five feet
deep all the way down into the bottom of
that goalie which was 40 or 50 feet down
what i'm thinking of is the
the
amount of bacteria pectoral bacteria was
going downstream
from this pile of potatoes
probably most of the pathogen did not
survive in this because the tubers were
so rotten
i want to talk a little bit about the
sexual cycle of this organism because
that's also important
this is a picture of an orgonium
and here's an antheridium so this is the
female structure this is the male
structure and a nucleus migrates from
the antheridium into the orgonium and
fertilizes
the oregonium
and
once that fertilization occurs then we
get a
an ospor
identified here and you see it's very
thick walled structure
these osbors can survive for years in
soil
as far as we know
that does not yet happen in the united
states
there are places in the world where it
does happen it certainly happens in
central mexico and the highlands of
central mexico
within the last 20 to 30 years we know
that it happens in
northern europe particularly in
scandinavia and also in northeastern
europe but in most places in the world
and i think also throughout the united
states
we don't know yet that oa spores
occur because we don't think sexual
reproduction is yet a factor in the
united states
so most people have heard about potato
late blight
because of the famine it caused in
ireland in
the mid 19th century
this book is actually a fascinating book
it's by a female author who took a male
pseudonym
um to write about it
um it says 1845 to 1849 it's really just
a chronicle
of what happened there's not much
emotion except the facts and figures are
so awful
that
they're just presented in a in a really
bald way
and
there were many
cartoons if you will in newspapers this
is one from that period in which
this represents ireland says help and
says we are starving
so the
irish potato family was really awful as
many of you know
this is late blight was not known to the
western world until 18
until the mid 19th century
and this is a picture of
the development of this new disease in
europe starting in 1845
the first occurrence was detected in
belgium at the end of june and then this
new disease
appeared
later in the season as we went through
the summer of 1845
until by the end of the season all of
ireland had been affected by the late
blight
one of the reasons that
ireland was so severely affected
is that
potatoes were just a huge
component of the
of the diet for people
for example
if you were among the the
lowest class the cuttier smallholders
and landless laborers
your calorie intake was from eating 12
pounds of potatoes a day
and this is for most of the year
and what but but so when that food
source was destroyed you can see what it
would do to one's um
one's calorie intake what i learned
which was really fascinating
is that potatoes probably caused a
population explosion in ireland
and there were no censuses in or sensai
in
in ireland in the 19th or 19th century
but it's estimated that the population
of ireland at the end of the 18th
century was about 3 million people
it's estimated that by the mid 19th
century it was about 10 million people
and potatoes had become a major calorie
source in the end of the 18th century in
ireland which enabled this huge
population explosion
and
it wasn't uncommon for mom and dad to
have 18 18 kids
they could subsist on
potatoes they could heat a one-room
stone house with pete
and it really created this very huge
population explosion
okay now i want to talk about migrations
um worldwide but mainly in the u.s
the reason i said mid-19th century for
western science knowing about this
disease
is because it appeared first
let's see
it appeared first in
the u.s
around maybe around philadelphia around
new york in 1843 and here's uh this
illustrates how it radiated out from
1843 to 1844 to 1845.
so one of the questions is where did
this organism come from
and i'm going to suggest to you that it
came from central mexico
there is a significant debate about
where this organism came from it was
debated at the end of the 18th century
and through the 20th century or at least
to until the middle of the 20th century
when everyone
that is most scientists agreed that
maybe it came from central mexico then
in the late 20th century some of my
colleagues suggested no it didn't come
from central mexico it came from south
america
where potatoes also originated
i think the developing data now will
confirm that it probably is
or originated in central mexico
so
sometime
let's see
sometime before
1842 it could have come
from
central mexico to the states
it could have come from the states to
europe sometime before june of 1845
and that would that's easy to imagine it
would an infected tuber could be taken
on a ship
taken to europe
the path you could sporulate from that
infected tuber and it could initiate
disease
or that one possibility is that it might
have come directly from europe excuse me
from central mexico to europe
from central europe
it's very clear as to how it moved uh
because there's a very active seed
potato trade from europe to the rest of
the world except to the us in canada
so potatoes go to south america to
africa to asia uh and and all over uh
from uh northwest europe so it's easy to
see how this organism could get around
in the late 1980s there was clearly
a migration from
northern mexico to the u.s
the reason i know that it was from
northern mexico is that we had been
sampling in sinaloa state
prior to
the occurrence of new strains
in both the pacific northwest and also
the east coast and had found the very
same genotypes of phytophthora
infestands
in northwest mexico before they arrived
in the united states
so it's really clear as to where
our populations came from in the late
1980s
what i want to illustrate to you is
again is how
interestingly and how fast this organism
can get around
we detected this particular strain of
phytophthora infestands
in the summer of night of
1992.
it was oswego county it was not in
ithaca it was not tompkins county it was
in oswego county
and then we got a sample from maine in
1993
which was also the same genotype and it
was again this usa
clonal lineage
in
the next year too
this same genotype was spread throughout
the united states
in 1994 it was in the eastern half of
the united states and in 1995
it affected all of the western potato
production areas in the united states so
this this
pathogen gets around in infected tubers
those infected tubers go from the potato
seed producing areas all over
from they go from
in this case maine all the up and down
the west coast new york produces seed
tubers michigan wisconsin minnesota
north dakota
uh idaho oregon and washington all
produce seed tubers and they go in
trucks so this organism gets around in
trucks for intercontinental
migrations
1994 when i took those pictures was
really a severe year
and
this picture was taken in in august and
what i wanted there were several reports
in the newspaper about
the
impact of this disease on pathogens this
is a farmer byron chapman who grew
potatoes near utica new york
he lost his entire crop in 1994 to late
blight
he declared bankruptcy the next year and
he died about a year or two after that
so my my
conclusion was that the stress of losing
his crop losing his farm was so severe
that it really caused him
cost him his life
it was all because of this strain of
phytophthora infestance
it was resistant to what had been one of
the most effective fungicides and people
when they saw late blight would spray
this fungicide methanoxan
expecting it to completely
halt the disease but it didn't and when
that didn't happen they didn't know what
to do and so
and this disease is so explosive that it
just destroyed these potato crops in
1994 and 1995.
okay so what happened in 2009
so from our own abby seaman we got this
note
on june 23rd 2009
she said to the late blight listserv she
said late blight has been found at
several locations in our reporting area
this past week and then here's a quote
from meg mcgrath on long island
she said a sample just came in there's
lots of sporulation the field had been
sprayed with fungicide
and growers are taking action
and then on the next day the 24th of
june 2009
um keith perry who's my next door
neighbor on on the third floor of plant
science building came in with a tomato
plant that was severely infected with
lake light
he said bill what do you think of this
i said wow
it's got late light
i said where'd that come from
lowe's
is where it came from so
um we went to lowe's and took pictures
so these are
tomato transplants that are that were
for sale
on june 24 2009
not only lowe's but walmart
home depot there was one more that had
these same transplants for sale
and they were really all heavily
infected with phytophthora investing
these are large lesions you know they
have been there for a while
and so these plants had been um
infected for really quite some time
so on the 24th of
june in 2009 there was we knew that
suffolk county had infected tomato
plants we knew that tompkins county had
tomato infected tomato plants
so here's a note from tom zitter on the
26th of june
in 2009 and it's really fascinating he
said yesterday i did a quick tour of
garden centers in the ithaca area all
three big retail stores had late blight
infected tomatoes on their shelves
yesterday afternoon some agreed to
remove the plants while i was there
while others were awaiting word from the
new york supplier
tomato plants have been replaced with
additional plants every few days and
then he said i also received word that
late blight infected plants from large
large retailers were found in cerro
pennsylvania schenectady county and as
far east as presque isle maine presque
isle maine is a
in
aroostook county
maine where there's
70 000 acres of potatoes being produced
so on the 26th these
counties had reported late blight
oops
by the 8th of july in 2009 these
counties had reported late blight
so at that point i thought you know i
better get out of plant science building
go look around
so
who who knows where this is
oh that looks like it's over near fall
creek yeah
you got it so this is on freeze road
and that's where i went
and here's what i saw
each of those spots is a late light
lesion
these uh dying and by the way this is a
tomato plant
um
and
these are dead and dying leaves and
infected by phytophthora infestants
in the same garden
i looked at potatoes
and sure enough they were infected also
and so by the 16th of june
there have been these many counties
reporting late blight in new york state
and by the 17th of august this many
counties had been reporting late blight
in new york state
so i thought i'd tally that you know
just do a cumulative
tally of the number of reports to our
diagnostic lab about late blight
and you can see that the first
event was in
mid-june and here's the report on the
23rd
here's the 24th the 25th
i want and then it goes way up to above
140 reports i want to compare that with
2008 the number of reports of late
blight in new york state so there were
three samples received by our diagnostic
by our diagnostic lab
none of them was late light they were
all suspected so there was zero late
blight in new york imported to our
diagnostic lab in 2008 but in 2009 we
had this um
this kind of reporting
i also thought i'd say that
37 of these 30 or 49 reports that were
occurred over a period of six days were
from retail stores which is was not
normal
and some of our colleagues in the state
from cornell cooperative extension would
go to store find that there was late
light there and suggest to the
manager that you have to get rid of
these plants they're a problem
so what happened was
that
some people
put them on sale to move them out
this is a
this is a picture of an organic farm not
too far from here
i was there in early august 2009
this they had 10 or 11 plantings of
tomatoes
this is either the 10th or 11th planting
it was only planting left they removed
everything else because it had been
affected by late blight
these were going to be destroyed and
moved very quickly because as you can
see they are very severely affected and
that story was repeated many times in
many locations
in 2009
this is a message i got from a lady
growing
tomatoes
in amsterdam new york or near amsterdam
it's just illustrative according to the
impact that this epidemic had
she said i am an organic gardener in
amsterdam new york with 63 heirloom
tomato plants of 23 different varieties
they're all gone
i was growing very rare varieties black
screens oranges whites
all purchased from a very reputable
grower in schoharie
tonight i had to leave home
as my husband is pulling and begging all
63 plants
i have 100 loss we live on 10 acres i
inspected every day and it seems the
blight took my plants in a matter of
hours
i was hoping to sell them for additional
income it always chokes me up i read
that
so
um that was repeated many times so the
question for us was you know what what
was this and what was the composition of
the pathogen population
in 2009
so we had received more than 70 samples
we do several types of assays with these
the samples that came from commercial
potatoes were usa the strain that we'd
been having seeing for really quite some
time but the ones from tomatoes were
something different and i'll illustrate
that to you here
um
this is a protein assay that we use
and one of the reasons is so great is we
can do this assay within about two hours
and haven't have an answer if we have a
spoilaging lesion we can do do that
assay very quickly
and for example here's the pattern that
we get with us-8
but in 2009 what we got was this pattern
which is which is rather different now
we also were doing
dna fingerprinting but the this assay
takes us you know four to ten weeks we
have to culture the organism get enough
dna to actually do a southern
and um
here's uh
this is the dna fingerprint for the us-8
strain of phytophthora infestands
and this these four columns represent
dna from four different individuals of
phytophthora infestands which have a
different pattern
and this one we named us-22 because the
the terminology had got to that point uh
by this time
so
that we had uh in the last several years
we've had various strains of
phytophthora infestations usaid is still
around
us 20 was dominant in 2009
and more recently us-23 and us-24
are dominant and the reason we can
identify specific strains is because of
asexual reproduction
so we get a clonal lineage it's all the
same thing
and some of these can be um very very
dominant and so it makes sense to
understand what they are
so back to 2009
we know that late blight was produced in
production facilities in both new york
and in maine
after the end of the season we we had
accumulated isolates from other places
and it turns out the same strain us-22
was was
found throughout the u.s
the question is where did it come from
and
here's the picture from lowe's
bonnie plants has a production facility
in alabama
and it's just very clear to me
that they shipped infected plants from
their production facility in alabama to
the production facilities in new york
and
maine
we met with representatives from bonnie
plants in
in november of 2009
and this is one of their responses
we don't ship plants we ship plugs
can somebody tell me what a plug is
it's a small plant it's a small plant
yeah
so they have they've never admitted to
doing anything
as far as they haven't been sued but
they've
when talks like mine happened they got
quite belligerent
um but they were the cause of this huge
pandemic
in 2009. they have
subsequently cleaned up their act quite
considerably tom zitter is consulting
with them and illustrating how
to prevent late blind
okay i want to move on to after
2009
and to focus on the needed ipm research
that has been happening what i want to
do is to focus on a tool that i think
can be really quite useful
this is a decision support system
which i think will enable integrated
management a very effective and
efficient integrated management of late
blight it takes into account the weather
and weather is huge in terms of late
blight development
it incorporates cultivar resistance
because there are some cultivars that
are
actually at this point immune there are
some that are quite susceptible and
others that are less susceptible
there are several forecasting schemes
that have been used in the us and it
contains those
is responsive to pathogen type and also
to fungicide sodium it's a tool to
enable a grower
to take account all of these
factors
what one of the most interesting things
to me is the location specific weather
you can get weather data
from the nearest weather station to you
some growers have purchased weather
stations so they have on-farm weather
data there's a transmitted
via telephone to actually to bradfield
hall
and in addition to getting previous
weather
uh the
weather center here gets weather
forecast for the next seven days
and those weather forecasts are
automatically downloaded um
to the system and the weather forecast
can be interpolated on a four kilometer
grid
so that you can have a weather forecast
that is specific within probably two
kilometers of view
for what the weather might be and that's
that's really important because late
blight can is very responsive to weather
there are these two disease forecasting
tools that are present in it
there is a late blight disease simulator
on which one can do experiments and i'll
say a little bit more about the
simulator later on
and there's an alert system that can
give you information about what to
expect
so let me talk just a little bit about
pathogen type
i mentioned
these lineages of phytophthora
infestands
in 2009 almost everything we found was
us-22 and that's because it was
transported on bonnie plants throughout
the northeast
and then
us-8 was also present but it was present
primarily on commercial potatoes and it
gets transmitted very effectively on
potato tubers
in
2010
we had a new lineage that began to
appear primarily in the western part of
the u.s it's us-24
also us23 began to appear uh wasn't real
dominant us 22 was still present
and us-8 was present
and the sample size is typically between
150 and 200 for each of these bar graphs
i didn't want to do that
in 2011
us24 became more visible and us-23
became even more visible whereas us 23
of 22 became less so
but in 2012
this last year almost everything we saw
was us 23.
it was
really
a surprise
so why is it
at all interesting or important to know
what lineage you have or that's near you
one of the reasons is that
some of these lineages are sensitive to
methanoxan others are resistant
and here's a figure illustrating that
this is us-8 and these plates are
phytophthora infestations growing on an
agar medium with either 0 5 micrograms
per mil or 100 micrograms per mil of
methanoxan and you can see that there is
some effect of methanoxine on the growth
of us-8 but there's still significant
growth
of that
clonal lineage on methanoxin
but if you look at us-22
here's growth in the absence of
methanoxiem at five micrograms per mil
or at 100 micrograms per ml and it's
really severely
um
restricted by methanoxan this
we put a five millimeter plug on the
plate so that's just about the diameter
of the plug that we put on the plate
us-23 is similarly sensitive to
methanoxime and us-24 is generally
sensitive to methanoxin so that if you
have a methanoxane sensitive strain
then you can use that fungicide
and that could be really quite effective
it also turns out that there's
difference in terms of host
preference
and what this slide illustrates is the
amount of sporulation that's how many
sporangies are produced on a particular
leaflet
for the various clone lineages here's
us-8 us-22 us-23 and us-24
and whether sporulation is on potatoes
or on tomatoes
and what this graph illustrates is that
a us-8 is
actually a hell of a potato pathogen as
we already knew
but it doesn't do much at all to
tomatoes
us-22
does something on potatoes but look at
what it does on tomatoes it really is an
aggressive pathogen and reproduces very
rapidly on tomatoes
us-23 is even more aggressive on
potatoes than is us-22 and even more
aggressive on tomatoes
and then finally us-24
is somewhat similar to us-11 in that is
a good pathogen on potato sporulates
very profusely on potato but almost not
at all on tomato
and so it really is important are you
are you growing tomatoes or are you
going potatoes
which pathogen is near you
and actually you can learn which
pathogen is near you
because the um
in on the eastern
part of the united states the extension
personnel have collaborated on making
reports
as to whether late blight is present
and
they send those samples to our lab and
we assay those and we can identify to
clone a lineage very quickly
what that um
what that is and for example this is
from 2012 it's a summary
map of the united states from all of
2012.
and essentially everything we got
from
the northeast part of the united states
this last summer was u.s 23.
again it's
that's a really effective pathogen on
both potatoes and tomatoes
um
what we use now are micro satellite
markers to distinguish the
different lineages of phytophthora
infestands
and i have data for
2011 by the end of october 2011 we had
received at least 140 samples
and
we returned around at least 80 of those
within 24 to 48 hours so the person
sending the sample had an idea of what
of what was present
so what i think and what we're hoping
for is to develop a strain specific
forecast that will be available on the
decision support system and i think that
will enable people to become really very
um
very knowledgeable about what to do
so cultivar resistance and fungicide are
both huge
and this is a picture of some field
experiments looking at cultivars at
freeville this is really a beautiful
image don't you think
um ian small took this image ian has
been working really hard
um and he is i think it's really a
gorgeous image i think he was there
early in the morning to go fishing
because the um fall creek is right there
and ian is really an avid fisherman so i
think this is even
but be that as it may we have a fair
amount of date about host resistance
for both potatoes and
tomatoes
this is a disease progress curve for a
susceptible cultivar and what the
y-axis illustrates is the amount of
disease that goes up to 100 which is all
death and this is time along the x-axis
and you see in a susceptible cultivar
you get this very rapid increase in
disease
for a moderately resistant cultivar
under the same weather conditions the
same inoculation condition to get much
less disease
so that's that's really important
fungicides obviously are really
important these vertical blue lines
illustrate
the um
the dates at which a fungicide was
applied so if fungus is applied to a
susceptible cultivar you can suppress
disease quite significantly with with
with fungicide
but a moderately resistant cultivar
doesn't need as much fungicide as a
susceptible one or put it the other way
a susceptible cultivar needs a lot more
fungicide than does a moderately
resistant one
the dss now has
cultivars by name and their their
category of resistance
at least 75 or at least 75 cultivars for
potatoes and we're in the process of
doing tomatoes but there are at least 50
cultivars of tomatoes that we can put
into the dss
in terms of fungicides
this is
there's there's been also a tremendous
amount of work this is a picture from
this last year
um
the the experiment this year had at
least 15 types there were several
different combinations applied to two
different tomato cultivars and two
different potato cultivars for something
like 70 treatments which was a
tremendous amount
but we use that information to put into
the dss and here's uh you don't have to
look at the you don't understand this
slide but it illustrates how we use that
information of different fungicides in
terms of a disease forecast
and this uh is a picture of steve mckay
who is doing the fungicide applications
and steve
was driving that tractor
about 15 miles an hour between plots
the boom was bouncing all over
but steve
it's my pleasure to recognize you today
for
steve's really significant contribution
in terms of
all the kinds of research that goes on
out at freeville
that he gets the
2011 excellence in ipm award
yeah i think anything else would be sort
of
anti-climactic so let me uh i'll skip
this
it's really cool but i'll skip it
okay so i think that with potato late
blight management i think
highly localized management this is
that's really targeted it's like
personalized medicine is for your farm
for your for that field for that
particular cultivar
uh will be really effective for 2013
what we hope to do
is to include
sort of a targeted forecast which also
brings into account the pathogen
presence or the lineage that's near you
and i think that should be able to uh
really help out
disease management and finally i'd like
to say thanks to people in my group
kevin myers who
is right back there
has done all of the microsats
and people all over the east coast
know kevin very well at least
electronically ian small has been doing
the
work on the dss which is wonderful
laura joseph is programmer who is just
amazing and giovanna danis is the person
who identified the
characteristics of
the strains of phytophthora infestands
and so with that i'll quit
and if there are any questions i'll give
them to steve
we would all love to know that the
answer to that question and we're we're
working on it
um
yeah so everybody wants to know where
are these things coming from and uh
yeah um
i think it was present in florida prior
to 2009
um but where it came before it was in
florida we don't know okay so there's a
twofold answer to that
um the first is that in 2009 us-22 was
spread throughout the u.s by
on infected tomato transplants so it was
just everywhere
it's not as aggressive as us-23 so we're
seeing it subside in in terms of its
prevalence and i think
um
so both things contribute you know
widespread distribution is huge
but aggressiveness can also uh make a
difference and so us 23 is more
aggressive it's
it's really going everywhere us 22 is
subsiding
um what we do when we have infected
plants we don't we're not worried about
we get we put them um into
black garbage bags
and let them heat up during the summer
and die that way
so um that's what we can do on a small
scale
but as far as we know again knock on
wood that that um
we don't think there's sexual
reproduction yet in the united states so
i think the soil itself is not a
reservoir of this pathogen if there are
infected tubers or there are other
infected plants somewhere that they
could be but we think you know osports
in the soil are not a source of the
pathogen as far as we know
growers do a lot of things um
some growers have used flame throwers to
destroy uh plants
um
they've sprayed a lot of fungicide they
after they've
they disk them up
what you want to do is get them get that
plant as dead as you can as quickly as
possible so the pathogen then dies
if there are two mating types in
phytophthora infestands if they come
physically in contact
there's sexual reproduction is likely
because we have clonal populations at
this point
even though we have both mating types in
the u.s we have one clone of one mating
type over there and one clone of a
different mating type over here and we
don't think they interact that much and
i think that's why we haven't seen
uh sexual recombination yet although
both mating types exist in the states
that's a com the answer is complicated
to that
um
with the sort of multi-genic resistance
that we've been focusing on we don't see
any lineage specific effect
if there's single arginine resistance
and yes there can be quite significant
differential effect
but at this point
ph2 and ph3
are resistance genes that
seem to be holding up at the moment
and there are a few tomato cultivars
with those resistance genes and against
this population of phytophthora infest
hands they are immune
you know how long we'll have this
population of phytophthora infestan is
anybody's
guess this has been a production of
cornell university on the web at
cornell.edu